Oh, um, well, this is awkward.
I'm, uh, apricadabra, I'm gone.
Okay, I forgot.
I knew I forgot about something.
I, I was like, hmm, am I forgetting something?
Whoa, abracadabra, I'm back.
Abracadabra, ooh, ooh, la, la, la, la.
My, what do you mean you're immersion?
I even said the magic word.
I was like, yeah, close my door.
Any type of muffling is good with me.
Zander, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome, guys.
But yeah, no, sorry.
was i swear it's a conspiracy i literally got on my pc i was like that was a good walk for for dad let me get on the pc and then i got like six messages and i was like oh i
was like oh
so so i had to answer all of that um i am a busy a busy a busy girl this week so busy yeah but first up I do want to say um thank you guys all for the support as always I'm really happy to do things I can do and want to do because of you guys and I can keep going because of all of your support so it really does mean a lot everybody uh thank you guys so much for all the support uh throughout my journey everyone um but yeah um anyway so today we are back back with Street Fighter 6 and I will have to let you guys know the last time I touched Street Fighter 6 was um last year when we did say gem slam that was a long time ago um so nephew isn't coming in until an hour so like at 2 p.m so it's just you and I chat it's just you and me um I should have asked him I mean I should have started my stream at 2 uh but You know,
I figured, because, like, apparently all of us are starting at 1, regarding the training session, because, hey, Capcom, I don't know if Capcom's going to swap to me.
They might be watching someone else right now, but, like, hey, Capcom, our stream will be on Capcom's channel.
I think it's, I don't know if it's, like, Capcom's, it's like the Street Fighter.
Oh, yeah, it is on, it's going to be on Capcom Fighter.
Oh, thank God, they're not watching me yet.
But at 2 p.m., they might swap.
to me uh later on so like that's why like i don't know when they're swapping to me there it's gonna happen i don't know it will happen somehow in some way uh we're gonna be that's why i have to i have to start at one uh so uh so that's why i'm here early uh but enough he's coming in on 2 p.m and he's gonna help me figure out what the fuck to play because like i said i am stuck for those who don't know all right so i forgot to tell the story on my youtube channel because i told it on twitch um because like you know i was playing rivals at four in the morning as one will be uh as one should be you know i dropped the bomb uh before my schedule was posted i like dropped the bomb and was like hey guys i'm gonna like um i'm these are my coaches for by the for
So basically, we are stuck between two characters.
Because for those who don't follow the, you know, Street Fighter patches, Zangief has gotten nerfed since the last time I played him.
Which is, you know, it's crazy to think about how dare they change my character after I haven't touched him for a year.
Like, what the fuck is this?
Like, how dare they?
It should be the same character after a year.
How fucking dare they nerf him?
So, um, so, um, this is what I was told by Justin, um, you know, Mr. Juan, um, because he was saying, yeah, he did get nerfed.
So, uh, not sure if you still want to keep playing Zen Keefe.
And then, so, you know, I had this conversation with Nephew about this because he's like my main coach for this entire tournament.
um and the tournament is on friday um and the entire tournament is on friday by the way it's not like stage i'm slam where we had the group like we had like you know the group stages on different days and then the finals on you know there's like two groups like there's like two days where it's group stages and then the third day is the finals this time it's like all is on one day so you can't really adapt to anything um so like what you get is what you get type deal so i also have you know my participation was announced a week ago i haven't touched street fighter this is going to be i mean i did touch street fighter yesterday a little bit but like you know i was going through the controls i was like i don't know what the i'm doing like i was like trying to go through the controls myself and like going through like the combo trials i was like i don't remember any of this and i don't even know what the i did none of these instructions make any sense to me um and I was going through like
Zangif and Honda and I was like none of these make sense to me.
It's not coming back.
Oh no.
I was like, oh no, it's not coming back.
It's not like riding a bicycle.
I was lied to.
Because I know like, no way.
When you get into the game and you start, you know, pressing the controls, it'll come back to you.
It did not.
It did not come back to me.
I was just like, oh no, no, this is bad.
I thought, like, you know, at least the same game I could, like, remember.
It did not happen.
I did not remember anything.
The bike is fighting back me right now.
So, so, so I don't fucking know how we're going to go through this without nephew for a bit.
And so anyway, so, you know, know, I was talking to nephew being like, what the fuck do I play?
Like, you know, as one should.
And yes, now know why, like, there's so many things going on last week.
There was no time for me to, like, even boot up Street Fighter with everything going on.
And like, you know, with like stuff I, you know, I had to like, you know, I was just catching up with people and all that stuff going on and all of that.
And then why I had to go to sleep.
So like, I was just going straight and all that shit so I was so busy last week in prep and in preparation to this this was like today was like you know yesterday was like the first day I got to actually touch the game and even then I was like what the fuck am I do I don't remember and I was like oh no why can't I remember I thought it was riding a bicycle I
I'll read what I said to Nephew.
Basically, I was like, or I'm looking through my messages to Nephew.
And I was like, I just want to play something that's easiest to abuse and make people the most angry.
Because Nephew was like, you can keep playing Zangip if you like them.
And I was like, I don't care.
I don't care.
give me the most easy character and something that can rage rage bait people i don't care who it is like so he was like oh oh um he's like oh saying keep is pretty good at that but like uh honda and then so that's why nephew was like you should try honda then because apparently he has this one combo that's just one button that's the most easily abusive so he's like and I was like yeah I I and then he's like and he's like oh but you could also learn JP and but then he was also like but I don't think you should learn JP because because it can get a little overwhelming for a new player which I I infer as super like you might be too stupid for JP and I agree I agree because I later said uh yeah I I was like I was like I can only know I can learn four moves.
I straight up was like, I can only learn four moves.
If you give me anything else, it's over.
It's GG's.
Like, because that's how I learned King.
And, um, yeah, he requires a Brit.
And like, even nephew before he was like, try JP is like, I don't think you should try JP.
He's like, JP is also one, but I don't think you should try JP.
because he's like jp tilts because he was saying like he was saying like what was it i like this guy he's like uh uh
oh my god where is this comment it was basically like honda makes people angry at low elo but jp can make any elo but then even then he's like i don't think you should learn jp like so so so i was like you're you're so right um but yeah uh because i'm like i i you don't understand like i i when i play zane gif and i play king um i just learned king it was two moves i'm pretty sure i learned two moves and then it was just free for all um so that's why like i was so unpredictable because i didn't know what i was actually doing on king and he was taken as much more button mashing friendly come but then like in street fighter in street fighter uh it was different because you can't oh and the low yeah the low kick was like my saving grace uh because like you know like the actual real players don't fucking think you would abuse the low kick because who the fuck does that i do that but like who the fuck does that i do it um um but like for a street fighter um it's a different story uh because
you can't really button mesh so you actually have to know exactly what the fuck you're doing uh because you're like there's no way there's no way she's gonna low kick again but I'll use it there's no way she'll use that low kick again but there is a way because for me I abuse it until it stops working and it kept working because they're like there's no way she'll do it again but I still kept doing it because they think I won't do it again because it's like the most stupid thing you can do anyway in Street Fighter uh uh yeah it's like when i kept using rock because they're like there's no way she's gonna pull out rock for the fifth time but i still i'm like rock the street fighter i actually have to know more moves um um and so that's why zanke was really good for me because all i had to do was just walk up to them and grab like it was just different forms of me up to them and grabbing them.
I'm like, oh, do I walk over there slowly?
Or do I walk over there really fast?
Or do I wait for them to jump at me and then I jump and grab?
Like, that's it.
That was my entire game plan on saying keep.
I literally was like, how do I grab you?
Like, nothing else.
Maybe I'll throw in a slap or two.
But majority of that was like, do I walk slowly or do I walk over really fast or do i like wait like but anyway i talked to also big bird from um you know big bird from also from street fighter he is my secret coach um that i didn't reveal until like the schedule was out because i'm collecting all the you know we're in the bird family you know got birds got to stick together so uh i won't now i almost have all the birds i'm just missing angry bird uh so in tomorrow to also coach me but i also talked to him too i was like what do you think should i also should what do you what character should i learn and even big bird was like you should try honda like it might be like the easiest and like the most abusable to pick up on so big bird and nephew both suggested honda that's why i'm conflicted right now so i don't know we're gonna stick with dogeef or we're gonna do do honda so we're today is the day where we figure
to stuff all this knowledge in this very tiny brain.
But, like, I think we can do it.
Like, it's just, the thing is, Honda apparently, like I said, he has only one move that's very easily abusable, one combo that's very easily abusable, and you just have to press one button.
And I like that, you know?
I really like that.
One button, not two, one.
Like, I can't fuck that up.
If anything, I just need a...
The second button would be me moving forward.
So I'm thinking like...
One button seems really, really doable, guys.
I don't know.
That one button just sounds so appealing to me.
Nephew did say it might take a bit for me to like understand Han.
as well because like yeah he said it requires charge moves I was like what the fuck is a charge I was like does that like am I charging like am I holding the button down like is that what you mean by charge move also I told him that he has to talk to me in like controller icons like I if he's like use heavy attack I'd be like what the fuck are you talking about is that x like
via PlayStation controller buttons, icons.
Because the icons are on my controller.
So that's how I know what to press.
So you might, some of the guys who are new here, who haven't watched my fighting game art before, I looked down.
I actually looked down on my controller.
Because when I was being taught how to play Zangief, when I was being taught how to play Zangief, and they were like, remember to use...
R2.
Remember to use like special heavy.
And I was like special heavy.
And he'll be like R2 triangle.
And I'm like, oh, R2 triangle.
I'll be like, yeah.
Nexi.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't even have to count it too.
Perfect for Doki.
Exactly.
Less numbers means maybe.
win zero muscle memory i'm trying to see what else uh nephew and uh big bird said yeah but yeah nephew's like honda is our best to abuse uh for best in for nubabusing so yeah so that's why today's the day we figured this out all right let me grab street fighter let me put up street fighter now um are my sound guys alive today chat I was a big bird was like what um what do you play modern or classic I was like of course modern like what the fuck I mean I'm literally in the beginning tier if you give me more than four controls like this the system might as well like fucking like blue screen uh one punch man meet one button a woman thank you for the super chat thank you thank you and I was like oh I play Brood was like,
I can't help you.
He was like, disgusting.
He was literally like, the next comment was like, sorry, I can't help you anymore.
Because it's like, I'm a, I'm a body player.
Eepie.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Tomorrow's my birthday.
Can I get an early happy birthday from my Kami Oshi?
Thank you for the super chat, Mike.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you Happy birthday dear Mike Happy birthday to you Yay!
Happy birthday Only the real birds Play Class.
Hey, I'm Baby Bird Okay, I'm Doki Bird I am like You know like Digimon where it's like Rookie, baby, rookie I'm literally baby like the little blob and you fucking You can like you can literally kill me As that tiny little blob Bro, never mind.
I'm not even the fucking blob in Digimon.
I'm the egg.
You ain't gonna teach an egg a classic controller, guys.
You ain't teaching this egg anything.
She's not taking it in.
All right.
Let me boot up this game real quick.
Street Fighter 6.
I got really scary because when I was like, when I plugged in my controller for the game, it started making beep, beep, beep, beep, and then I panicked and unplugged my controller because I think my PC was actually going to blue screen if I kept it in a little longer.
So I hope my, I hope my FG, like my fighting game controller would be okay.
Because that worried me a little bit.
Street Fighter 6 Street Fighter 6 Alright let me get the Street Fighter in Oh my god It's been so long since I've seen this It's oh my god It's been so long since I've seen this screen I have not seen my sound guy Talk at all so I'm a little worried Which one is it?
It's the Razer one It's not the What is it called the Was it about the junkie?
Is it the junkie?
I don't remember the other brand.
It's the Razor one.
Because this is the...
Oh, the snack box.
Yeah, the snack box.
It's not the snack box.
Because the only reason why I haven't used the snack box one.
Is because it doesn't have the...
Oh, it's junk food.
It doesn't have the controller icons on the controller.
No.
like I mean I could get a marker and draw the icon on it no no okay I gotta feed him a little bit he's a little bit of a bratty yeah so and I keep telling myself okay if I have more time I can learn it without seeing the controller icons on my um on the controller but I never really had always had the time um to actually like uh learn the controller because this is the same controller i've been using since the very first stage am slam um for techin so so my brain has never processed what button does what i just know i just look at the controller icons uh back
even this food
oh yeah i don't even know where light punches that you can tell you can speak in color like i know like some people are like oh it's the blue button i'm like what the fuck is the blue button my controller is black like in my in the snack boxes is white colored like i don't know what the you're talking about for blue button or red button like that makes zero sense to me all right okay why is my controller not registering hello hello okay let me pre-plug this oh oh there we go oh my god okay i'm like i don't know what i'm doing all right so okay so it just i just need you to know i did try to see if i remember zangief and i will say i definitely did not
because they're like oh why learn a new character wouldn't it be easy to just try and remember everything else and i was like if it was not easier it was not easier i might as well start from zero all right i might as well um oh yeah okay so also when i told my thumbnail maker like oh yeah um i would be doing a coaching session with nephew at first she wrote um She wrote on the thumbnail Coaching my nephew She thought I was She thought I was actually coaching a nephew out of play street fighting.
I was like no no no That's his name
No, that's his actual name and I'm not coaching my nephew Okay.
Okay.
I did look up this, though.
But why is it who's saying my loyal fans?
I was so confused.
I was like, I thought you said my loyal fans.
But that's the only thing I looked up.
I was like, I need to know how to do this.
My loyal fans.
But I'm confused.
Oh, I have to be low HP.
that's why I kept this oh yeah you're right that was literally my Hail Mary every time I was so used to I was I've been so used to saying my loyal fans that every time I used it he was low HP it was literally my fucking rider my clutch your kick moment yeah
press left triangle this oh yeah this one oh I remember this I remember just he was like, stop doing that.
I can't do it.
I don't even know.
Like, I heard his damage.
He got nerfed.
Yeah, no, oh my God.
It got nerfed a lot.
Oh, wait.
So that's this.
I feel like his damage did get nerfed, right?
Oh, wait.
Watch this.
Wait, not this.
Sorry.
How did I do it?
No, not like that.
Stop watching.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure this out.
Stop watching.
No, give me a sec.
It was so cool.
Also, I think my sound guy is not alive.
Is it too loud?
Guys, is the game too loud?
I pushed it down a little.
I do have any mods alive.
Oh, shit.
It wasn't this.
god it was so cool i'm just trying to remember how i did it how did i do it oh my god wait oh wait i i figured it out okay watch this oh it wasn't that sorry but that was cool too i was like whoa i should have done this i could have done this guys oh my god i realized like wait a minute i could Why did I not do that in game?
Why did I never figure it out?
Why did I wait for him to wake up?
Yeah, look at that.
Look at that.
New tech unlocked that I'm going to forget at the actual game.
If I ever, like, get...
Like, I think that's cool.
I think this is cool.
Yeah, if it has to be the wall bounce or when, like...
When, like, uh, they jump to me.
Yeah, the...
Damage is so low, that's the thing.
That's the only thing that I don't like.
Like, look how little the damage is.
I would have, I would have fucking sent this man to the hospital after that one move.
Like,
that man should have been in the hospital, guys.
Like, you know, what?
So, like, I don't know if I like that.
So, yeah, I don't know.
I don't know.
I don't know if I'm gonna...
That's nearly everything I could remember.
Other than... I mean...
Yeah, no, that's actually... Wait, how do I do y'all?
How do I do y'all, guys?
Guys, how is it?
What move was it?
Give me the...
The controller icon.
Give me...
What was the controller?
Oh, what the fuck is SPD?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Is that R2?
Is it this?
No.
Um.
Triangle?
No.
Wait.
What is that?
How?
Speed?
SPD as in speed?
Secret GifTech.
Tap forward, back down.
Okay, you already gave me too many.
That's too many buttons.
I'm sorry.
I see.
Tap forward.
back and then I stopped reading.
I'm so sorry.
It's not you.
It's actually my brain.
Angry is thank you.
It is super chat.
Thank you.
I can't read past four controls.
Oh, it's this.
It's this.
Okay, it's triangle.
We figured it out.
It's triangle.
Alright, what do we do?
Triangle and then how do we do yihah?
How do we do yihah, guys?
I got triangle then.
I'm I'm a modern.
Modern controls on a PlayStation.
Try.
Okay.
Wait, that's not y'all.
Where the fuck is my y'all?
Okay, I need to jump on the right side.
I still can't play on the, I mean left side.
I still can't play on the, oh.
R2?
Oh my god, y'all!
Y'all!
Alright, that's all I know.
That's literally it.
That's the extent of my knowledge.
Okay, now let's...
How do I swap characters?
Oh, return to characters to that.
Alright, that one.
Yeah, that's IHOP.
And now we have DoHonda.
Alright.
See, I told you guys.
This is how...
See, when...
The people who knew exactly how I processed...
Gap gave me the...
Instantly gave me the right controls.
They're like...
What the fuck is she talking about?
And the other, it's like one side is like, I don't understand what she wants us to say.
And the other one's like, back triangle.
And I'm like, that's my boy.
That's my boy.
You know what it's up.
All right, how do I play Honda?
All right, what are the, what are the, what are the PlayStation control buttons, guys?
Oh my god, why does it show, like, colors for...
Okay, give me a sec.
Control settings.
There we go.
That should be it, right?
Wait, because...
Wait, what?
Wait, how come it doesn't show?
I need you to show the PlayStation.
Oh, wait, command...
Wait, I want to make sure it shows...
controller icons.
It won't?
What do you mean it won't?
That's fucked.
What?
Say that?
Right here.
Isn't it here?
Yeah.
Show input.
Show it.
Yeah, I want to show input.
Why doesn't it show me?
Do I do like attack?
Is that what it is?
No, it's still colors.
Hello?
How am I supposed to realize what the fuck I'm doing?
Oh no, where is it?
That button.
I'm so confused.
Where's the doki option?
Where- Charge move, hold back, push forward, and attack.
What's the attack button?
Oh, is it the stream setting?
Wait, what does that mean?
What does that mean?
Where is that?
Attack?
Uh-oh.
Avatar?
Oh, no.
Any attack.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, what's the dokey?
Where's the dokey option?
So true.
I need it to be a dokey.
Where's the dokey accessibility here?
I wanted to show the icons on the left side.
I don't know what the fuck blue-yellow is?
you change it?
Um, if you change the one, it shows Xbox instead of controller.
That's why I have to choose that.
Is it in character select?
Well, I'll try.
No, that's not it.
That just tells me to do modern.
Oh, games should be a little louder.
Okay.
I'll boost it up a louder here.
All right, Let me know if it's better.
What do the colors mean?
What do they mean?
I know N means neutral.
Whatever that is.
But yellow, blue, SB for speed, red.
That makes no sense.
DI?
What am I fucking getting my DUI right now?
Being my license revoked?
Like, the colors.
What do they mean?
This?
Or...
Wait, how do I... How do I do the...
There we go, okay.
This one, right?
Is that the...
Hold for about one second.
Alright.
Left triangle.
Like that.
Do I just do this?
Also do the down triangle.
Oh.
Oh shit!
Okay.
That's the classic.
Alright, do that.
How come that...
What the fuck?
How come this one is not consistent?
Okay.
It's like really weird.
It's not consistent.
It's not consistent at all.
It's like, like, if I stop, oh, wait, okay.
Yeah, see, if I stop, if I stop, oh, it requires a charge up.
How do I, what do you mean by, oh, yes, I can hold back.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so that's what he means by charge up.
I was like, what the fuck does nephew mean by charge up?
Okay.
All right.
So I just have to keep going back and then just do that.
Alright, what else?
What else do I have to learn?
Okay, that makes more sense now.
That's why it's the down charge up?
Like...
Is it charged up?
Is it... is it... is that charged?
Do you think it's charging?
Yeah.
Oh, down, up, charge.
Alright, like that?
You think it's charging?
Oh, press up and, uh, oh, press up and button after charging.
What the fuck?
Down to up?
Like that?
No, okay, no.
Up plus, okay.
Oh, this!
Oh god, that is a lie.
So what is the combo?
Is it this?
Oh shit!
Wait, that shit goes high.
This is my auto.
Is that the auto?
The abuse?
No?
Don't wait.
He told me it's one button.
What is... Oh, what's the butt slab?
What's the butt slam?
People were saying butt slam is also really good.
Butt, stop, head butt.
Oh fuck, stop.
I have to stop?
Wait, what was the butt slam?
I did a butt slam?
Oh, this?
Is it that?
or oh the one where i do down oh okay i'm charging give me a sec you think my team will let me charge when you you think when my team sees me do this like i'll be like give me a sec give me five one to five seconds guys give me you think you'll know what i'm trying to do Dude,
dude, do you think they'll know?
I would be like, time out!
Time out!
Okay, now come closer.
Come closer, guys.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, this seems very hard to tap.
Okay, I'll be like, give me a sec!
Give me a sec.
Brother, I don't know.
Guys, I don't know anymore.
I don't know if I'm...
I don't...
I think I'm cooked.
I have three days.
I think I'm cooked, guys.
We'll see if Nephew can salvage any of this.
He's going to grab some tape.
You know how, like...
You, like, you broke something...
You dropped something on the floor.
And he's going to grab a tape and just, like, grab all the pieces in his hand.
And just start taping it.
into a ball that's what he's gonna be doing to this brain right now uh he's not even gonna like arrange things correctly it's just it's just a pile of a ball of pieces with fucking tape around it and like you can do this um fatu asu thank you super chat thank you thank you you gotta get close and use up to use a butt slam back up and try it down up and attack okay i'll try that you all right oh i haven't charged it up yet oh shit oh my god all right time out
oh wait i fucked it up time out wait what oh wait what give me a sec i'm still charging it i'm still charging it Okay, wait, back up.
It's not working as worth that.
What the fuck?
Why is it charging?
My kami-hami-ha isn't working.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I have to, like, it has to be really fast.
Yeah.
I'm gonna timeout!
Oh my god.
Timeout again!
what the fuck i have to like hit it so fast
yeah i have to hit it so fast
all right oh he was a google engineer he's he's gonna be he's so used to talking to people like me then
i'm like the the assurance.
Alright, is there anything else?
Well, he did quit.
I'll give him fond memories of his time working at Google.
I wish I could use the junk food snack box, but like, I need to grab a marker and actually draw a controller icons on it.
That's like the only way.
I Don't change, like, for me, when I remap buttons, I, like, I remap them based on what it's on, what are the controllers on the thing.
Like, not, like, the controllers itself being remapped.
All right.
You can headbutt people.
How do I headbutt people?
Or color it in.
Yeah, or color it in.
You're right.
Coloring might be easier.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hold down L1.
Wow.
Hold down.
Press triangle four times.
That is two buttons.
You can do it.
Oh, you mean my L2?
Wait, you mean my R2?
This?
Yeah, I re-binded that.
Is it this?
Is that what you're talking about?
Are you talking about my auto?
I don't know.
I don't know Angrius.
Because, like, L1 is my shield.
That's my shield.
Oh, do this as a chargeback?
Then...
Wait, that's not it.
That doesn't look right.
Is that what you're talking about?
Or is that what you're talking about?
No, L1.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, no.
That's R2.
R2 is my auto.
As you can see, watch my button mash.
surprised how fast I can press my...
Oh, okay.
This and then...
Wait, this and...
That?
Okay.
And...
Everyone's always so surprised.
But...
When I had to do a combo, when I had to do a combo on Zangief, it was like...
Looks like a good.
That's how fast.
Frame 1.
I'm doing frame 1 button matching.
Yeah, I'm surprised my controller has survived two stage-time slams and also this now.
Is the controller?
Okay.
Look, see?
Whoa!
That's how I play my fighting game.
Whoa.
Oh, well, I'm to the left, to the right, I'm shimmying.
My little, my AD, this is why I learned an FPS game.
They can't predict this if I'm AD strafing all the inputs.
Look at that.
Pat your S here, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Instead of square, try X or O to charge your specialist light.
the X or O like this?
Wait, what's the difference between this and the other one?
Okay.
Alright.
Bob to the left can't hit me if I moved a little bit to the right.
Again.
Whoa.
Hades strafing in my fighting game.
Alright, what else?
What else should I learn?
The damage.
Oh, speed, damage, and distance changes?
Which one has the most damage?
Which button is the most damage?
Blue?
Which one's blue?
Blue.
Okay.
Square.
Alright, guys, this is how.
Blue is square?
Guys, blue is square.
Yellow is X.
Circle.
Oh, you guys remember.
And then speed is triangle.
Okay, so I assume circle does the most damage because that's the red, right?
All right.
So this would do more damage.
Really?
Does it?
Okay, head's a P. Oh, yeah, it does.
Now this one's A.
And this one's also A.
All right.
Red.
Red is O.
Or circle.
Sorry.
Oh, yeah.
circle all right auto is r2 drive impact is r1 block is block is this hey there girl is uh dp is l1 and then grab grab is l2 okay where's l3 do i have anything on these two buttons i have l3 an r3 i don't even know what that's for i remember in techin that was what i did for uh for like my special i just pressed that one button all right block is very hard block is just this but we don't go back we always go for it since diagonal is both down and left you can do a headbutt and butt slime after what the fuck one two three okay that's four moves okay sorry i might do the one was three moves patchy as two because like that three is smaller than four um okay this and then that all right yeah the dui is oh dui is r1 um let's see i'll do that wait is that blue as in like light or blue as in is that is your circle is your circ blue circle do you mean blue circle as in the blue circle or i just want to be sure the blue circle is it the blue circle or do you mean the circle controller button
like um i i know that's a very stupid question but like i want to be Sure.
That is the light button, which you mean the square button.
You mean the blue circle as in the square button or the blue circle as in the circle button.
I mean any attack.
Then why the fuck did you give me a blue circle?
You're frying the Doki GPU right now.
You're not, wait, no, the Doki CPU.
You are frying the Doki CPU.
GPU at the moment.
Okay.
That, as in, uh...
Didn't Brian make a video for you?
You sure did.
He sure.
Now you see why...
Why Nephew was like, we don't need to try JP.
I mean...
What doesn't hurt doesn't kill me.
Okay.
Wait, that's not JP.
Sorry, they were both old with beards.
It's easy to be confused with.
What doesn't... Hey!
Oh, wait, he should be ready.
Okay.
All right, he's ready whenever.
All right.
Let me make sure...
What the fuck?
How the fuck you set anything up?
All right.
That's enough.
I realize that's enough for me.
My brain was already overloaded.
I realize that it just wasn't it.
My arc is over.
It was a good practice, though.
It was...
It was a good practice.
all right all right we're getting the vc with nephew let me make sure let me set up my boogie shit too uh and all right sound guy get ready you're gonna help me with sound for nephew i think he's like a really calm person which will be very interesting
hello hello hello hello let me set up my my boogie real quick and then i'll be good to go oh yeah and then i guess also share my screen i feel like that's sort of important uh i can invite you to a room first and we can go over okay nice that's that's better are you are you just dokey bird yeah yeah oh wait no it's oh it's it's not not dokey oh yeah everyone this is nephew he's gonna to fix this i think i can't find it not dogeef they're
like a is there like a not dogeef yeah it's not dogeef wait let me copy and paste i got it yeah yeah why don't i look at invites again it's just been so long how do i accept invites it's like in fighting ground you go all the way to the right where it's like online oh okay and it's just custom room yeah and then invitations oh okay nice
all right i can only fight on the left side but they won't know that okay okay yeah they definitely won't know that as long as i can get the left side like it will be fine i think yeah just sneak over there first yeah yeah yeah they won't know they're not gonna watch this vibe i hope yeah yeah i don't think so all right did you do you want to go over honda first or yeah you want to go over gif i think i i think i would try honda first just to see like if i if i fuck with him and if i don't then i go back to the gif yeah that makes sense yeah you want to switch you you got to switch your character here and then go to the bottom one wait how do i oh my god how do i swap characters uh you press um your light button i think that's my x but okay wait no that's my square button okay oh yeah you have to talk to me and playstation controller icons because that's the only way i can i think that's the only way i can register anything i think it's square all right oh how come i can't leave yeah
um you have to click the the one you're in first to leave it and then You have to click training.
I'm doing it.
Oh, it's just day one, guys.
It's just day one.
Day two, it'll be better.
All right.
Can I go on the left side?
Yay.
Okay.
So the core of your strategy is just going to be spamming headbutt and butt slam.
All right.
So there is like an, so the easy way to do headbutt is you hold back.
back and do like your special let me turn on your inputs
yeah yeah like that um and that and then if you want to do butt slam let's just charge down and then up yeah like i my chat was trying to teach me the butt slam but it's like it's so fast the input for it it's it should be the same as headbutt like you're getting it it's like yeah because sometimes i do that oh i see yeah you just have to just let go of down and press up really fast i guess oh okay yeah because it's not consistent for me for this one yeah maybe you could try like pressing up and punch with your with the same hand to make sure you get the time because the problem is you're pressing up like way earlier than the oh okay okay also how much how much time you have to do for charging it is that i i think it's like a little bit less than a second all right
oh i'm getting it i'm figuring it out so it's just these two moves yeah if you can just keep spamming them that'd be that'd be really good i think okay yeah so just right after you do it you can start charging right again so you can do like you can basically do do another one right way after doing one oh yeah oh yeah also to make it easier to spam you could do like the special move button so you know how you have like a special move button yeah that's that's my the triangle wait the one the one you're pressing right now okay triangle okay um yeah if you if you just hold back and you press special okay yeah okay then you can just keep holding back so it it'll make it easier to spam too this one just does a bit less damage but it's fine you're able to just get charged better oh yeah no this is very easy to spam yeah yeah and then if you want to do the ex version you just hold auto to which is your that's my r2 yeah yeah so that one has a hit of armor but it's punishable but yeah um
basically like you know me if you're a meter back okay so do one head but try to try to do like two headbuts in a row
okay wait wait a minute
yeah but do do the regular ones not the x-arms okay
uh i don't get why it doesn't charge that much
So if you press, if you do the regular headbutt right away, like you'll get hit because like it's my turn after technically.
So normally we want to like wait a second after, but you can steal a turn with the EX one.
So if you do like a regular headbutt into EX headbutt because it has armor, you'll blow through it.
Like that.
Oh!
Wait, that's okay.
Yeah, but if they call it out and they block the whole thing, then you're punishable.
So I just have to do like a mix up.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I would say most of the time you just keep doing the regular one and then once in a while you can do the EX one But how do you counter the the the R2 triangle one?
The R this one?
The speed you can just you just punish it after like after you block it then you just punish it It can also get grabbed.
Yeah, but Yeah, the only downside really is that it's on safe oh yeah all right then you remember like oh about drive impact you're just driving back back that's all i was yeah okay so after you see it yeah yeah then after you get that um you just do your heavy auto combo do you remember how to do that um so you hold on so you hold i think um What is the R2?
Can you press R2?
R2.
Yeah.
Hold that and then mash, mash heavy.
I don't know what that is.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's pretty much going to be your main combo.
You just mash that out.
All right.
So if you only have a level two, you can do your medium ones.
So you just hold auto and do press your medium thing that's, um, Oh, that's square.
Oh, square.
Okay.
No, that's oh, no.
Oh, um, yeah, that one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's your level two.
Yeah.
So those are like the combos you want to do to cash out.
If you're up close, you can also do like your auto light combo.
So that one's you're with your square.
Oh, that one.
Yeah.
so you can that one's safe so you can just do it whenever okay yeah but other than that let me see yeah so this move is a command grab so if you get up close you can command grab them something you could also do is you could yeah do like this one into a command grab oh is that oh it's this one okay yeah it's that one on block wait how do i oh it's how do you do that with that oh then wait how do i do that combo about you hold r2 oh oh okay yeah but you you don't want to do that last hit you see there you you like stop it yeah oh and then that okay yeah or other than that like any other time you get close you can do this oh so Just a triangle.
Yeah, if you just see them blocking because they're scared, you can just walk up and do it.
Oh, I see.
I see.
Oh.
I tried to do this.
I can't.
Yeah.
And...
Oh my god, it's so hard to do the butt stab.
I'm like, not consistent.
Yeah, I'm sure you can get consistent though by Friday.
It just takes a bit of timing out.
I think the only problem is you're pressing the punch or the punch too early or too late.
Too late after that.
And sometimes you're not getting enough charge.
But that one you press the punch too late.
Yeah, and if you want to spam it, you have to right after you press it start charging down again.
No!
Good timing.
Okay.
I feel like I'm waiting too long.
Yeah, you're waiting, you're waiting.
I can show you where it's like.
Oh shit, you can do it that fast?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
You're just waiting too long to start charging.
Is the fuck you can do that?
Like as soon as you press the other two buttons and you start pressing down again by itself.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, give me a sec.
I guess we're good.
I don't think I don't know.
I don't know.
I mean we can we can take it.
we can save this for later but that's like yeah that's a trump card they'll never expect it yeah if you can get this one at least this one's already really good
what do i do after that again uh the heavy auto combo so it's you hold r2 it's uh the other one yeah so if you don't have level three it won't go into the level three you'll just get like the other parts of it but if you do have level three it'll cash out
wait could you like after this kid you like break down all the buttons yeah i don't know if i'm processing this right now i the only thing i could remember right off my top of my head is this yeah sure i can write it down like can you um i need to i need to figure out which buttons are which for you so can you press yeah like all your buttons and tell me what they are so this is This is triangle.
This is X.
This is circle.
This is...
Wait, what is this?
This is drive impact.
Oh, DUI.
Okay.
Why is it not showing up on my left side?
R2 is the...
Oh, R2 is auto.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
R2 is auto.
L1 is my block.
Uh-huh.
And L2 is my grab.
Do you have any other buttons found?
No.
These are all my buttons.
Do you have any other buttons that you could potentially use that aren't found right now?
I have L3 and R3.
okay are those easy to press for you they're like at the top of my controller okay i would recommend binding one of those to super um so if you open up your control settings yeah can you share can you share your discord yeah yeah yeah let's see it
um so scroll down and where it says heavy plus special press whichever one you want you Yeah, press R3 or L3.
All right.
Yeah, and then go back.
Oh, oh, oh.
Um, um, uh, no.
Press no.
Todd is very important.
You know what?
I should put that in.
I, yeah.
All right.
Yeah, check.
Nothing else got unmapped first.
Yeah.
Okay.
That looks good.
Okay, it was time.
So then, so you put, what, L3?
Yeah.
Yeah, so this is your super button now.
So if you're not, if you're knocked down especially, it's good to just wake up and do it.
So you can just spam it when you wake up.
Yeah.
Because it's invincible.
Something you can also do when you're knocked down is hold forward NDI to get dry reversal.
Yeah, hold forward and drive him back.
Oh, I would this.
Yeah, or you hold both of them while you're waking up.
Oh, OK.
All right.
It's only when you're knocked down, you start holding both of them.
Oh, OK.
I get it.
Yeah, like you won't get it if you're like, so it's it's yeah, it's basically invincible.
And then I try to hit you.
Oh, yeah.
But it costs two of your drive gauge bars.
okay but that one's fine to do so you either do that or super if you if you really don't want to block uh-huh uh and then for anti-ring if you have charge you can just um do headbutt okay oh that's not what i want to do but that works you can just like wait and be like holding down back or back and use headbutt oh
Yeah.
I see.
Oh.
Yeah, you just have to make sure to time it a little bit for like right when I'm landing.
So you still have the anti-armance ability.
Yeah.
Are that?
How come sometimes you can hit me?
I think it's if you're doing it too early.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
yeah that's the idea though you just keep spamming that how do you like counter this oh like when they just slap me okay okay yeah they have to they have to block one and then yeah yeah press a button after but a lot of new players won't even know when when it's their turn after so they might just get hit uh-huh so you just basically do this in the corner until they block me yeah how do i make do i by mixing it up i just do this like oh wait would you do like the just to mix it up yeah if they're blocking it you can do that to mix it up or if they're if they're like knocked down you can do your down special let me open up your down triangle oh down triangle okay yeah okay
oh my it um
yeah but you want to time it for like when i'm waking up at least yeah i want to just whip it oh hey okay so just when you're about to wake up like that yeah yeah that's perfect and then if you think they're gonna block you just stop doing that and you do your down triangle okay so just do that mix up on that Yeah,
and then a lot of people will get start getting scared and doing Their drive impact so sometimes you can sometimes you can just wait for it like that'll work up close But okay, it's not gonna work.
So you just wait and you die back and then you get your heavy Your circle plus R2 What would I do after the drive impact?
Oh the heavy the heavy.
Yeah That's not it but I don't
Yeah, I feel like that's enough for you to start out with.
Yeah, that was like four moves.
That's that.
Yeah, yeah.
That's it.
I got this.
It's four moves.
You want to try some rank matches and we can see?
Oh, we get annihilated by the bots.
Let's get, uh, uh, it's gonna be harder because you're gonna fight back.
Yeah, they will fight back.
It's crazy.
all right let me get it in yeah also let me check your settings um or yeah google go out of that and then go in options i think press like start yeah options on the bottom right yeah and then go to graphics oh yeah no it's all the way up it's it's it might be like in the highest graphics possible yeah do put input delay reduction on okay um Where's that?
It's the bottom one.
Oh, here.
Yeah.
That'll just make it a bit easier for you to react to stuff.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, that should be good.
Go online.
Not searching.
Where is it?
Why is it paused?
Oh, there it is.
That's how you can go into training while you're Yeah, you can.
There's a faster way.
If you go back, go out, go out again, and then press square in this menu.
Oh!
Yeah, it's a it's a secret they added.
Oh my god, it's like a little easter egg.
Yeah, and then open matchmaking telling you and you should be able to do it.
Come on guys, like a little bonus guys chat.
Look, did you guys know that chat?
It again.
Where are my bots?
How is it searching opponents like that?
Just give me a bot.
You want a bot?
I thought like when you first start the matches, doing ranks, they'd give you bots at first, don't they?
It says you've played seven matches with Honda.
When the fuck?
What the fuck?
Oh yeah!
Yeah, no, I remember now.
I got absolutely destroyed.
And then we swapped the game.
I remember.
But maybe, maybe now you'll...
Yeah, maybe now.
Now that I'm not button mashing on Honda, it should get easier.
Oh shit.
Confirm.
Here comes a new challenger!
Oh my god, he's ironed.
He's so good.
He's not iron yourself around you.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Hello, ma'am.
I just just hold back and like, yeah, keep keeping your eyes out.
Oh shit.
She fights back.
Don't worry about that.
Hello.
That's not cool.
What?
Wait, how the fuck?
Oh my god.
Huh?
Get off of me.
Oh.
What the fuck?
She's like adapting.
Yeah, it's when you're knocked out and you hold forward in DI.
Oh, hold forward.
Yeah, okay.
Forward DI.
That's crazy.
Get off of me!
Get off!
Oh shit, okay.
That's fucking red.
Get off!
Get off of me!
Nice.
Yeah, you just said I've been late there.
That's why you're super didn't come out.
That's why, okay.
Oh shit, dang!
Yay!
Yeah, I think we're looking good.
Leave me alone!
Oh, she can't touch me.
Yay!
Guys, the ground pound is too...
That's like level three for me, as I'm not there yet.
I'm not level three.
Get out!
Yay!
Oh my god, my record!
I don't even- I did that!
No, we can get a 505 though.
He's got to win the next two.
All right.
Oh my god, I forgot to win and done her.
It's been so long.
Why would you win and done her?
Because I know she wants a rematch.
It makes her the most mad.
Uh-huh.
Get away from...
Get
out of here.
Yay!
Oh, nice!
Just stopped at the right time.
Round two.
Oh no, oh no, don't touch me please.
I'm sorry ma'am.
Oh no, he's fighting back.
Yeah, when you're burned out, you can also, you still have access to your supers.
Okay.
Either L3 or R3.
I forget which one.
One of them is clunk.
Yeah, that one, that one.
Get off!
Get off ma'am!
What the fu- That's okay.
Get off!
Okay.
How do you tell what they like block my grab?
I'm worried.
There's nothing to be worried about.
I think their game plan is good right now.
Okay, nice.
That's good.
They can't adapt to me on the tournament day.
Not like last time.
Yeah, that is true.
They can't adapt to me.
And even if they could, the strategy is honestly really hard to deal with.
Okay, that's good.
Especially if you can start doing the bus slams.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
That's for day two Doki.
Day two Doki will pick that up.
If I learn a fifth move, I think my CPU would crash.
Yeah.
There you go.
What were you about to say?
I don't remember it.
This is why I can't learn a fifth move.
Are you like a Pokemon?
Yeah, you learn five.
If I have to learn a fifth move, we gotta delete a fourth move.
Oops.
We had to delete something.
Hello there, sir.
Oh, my God.
Silver.
You're so high rank.
That was my rank from last Sage Jamstab.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
oh my god oh no they figured my strat
it's not cool bro oh no he goes square balls you just gotta jump over them to get close first he knows oh no stupid fireball if i was saying beef i would grab that yeah you can also try di if you're a bit closer but you have to get close first because otherwise you can't really head but oh
no okay let's try and wait a little bit
oh oh no my grab what the fuck what is he doing what is he doing to me okay so Yay, Sylvia!
I leave.
I don't like...
I don't like him.
That's fair.
I don't like you fought back.
Yeah, the fireballs, I think, kind of counter what you've learned so far.
Yeah.
You have to start jumping and you can try and just jump and do your heavy auto combo.
Okay, so just jump.
Is there like...
Is there a grapple for your Honda when they jump?
or no um not not like eaves no uh i wanted to grab him so bad yeah you just have to press a button so you press like your heavy button in there oh just like slap him yeah just slap him down you want to try and time it if they're on the ground still so that it's them oh i see oh my god i play silver that was the the rank i ended on gif it's already going up guys we're already getting Yeah.
Yeah, your GIFO is like silver four though I think I saw so we gotta win a few more.
I'll win a few more.
I can't, I know right, why can't every character have a GIF grapple?
Should be like a GIFO.
I don't think that would be good for the game.
If every character had a GIF grapple, it's balanced.
well yeah everyone will have anti-air yeah I keep forgetting I could mix it up with this yeah but you don't have to if the other one is working okay my other silver players dragons queue up not that I'm playing your silver but like I need more players to play against please I need my practice guys also yeah said but some of it has armor like it can also go through fireballs so if you're just charging wait not that it's the yeah the yeah that one so if you're just holding charge and you can try and go through a fireball like that oh i see okay where
are my rinkers come on three fighter six is alive you can try turning it to three to five for the network settings oh nice here comes a new challenger big
schlop oh my god oh my god he jumped It's like he's played against Honda before.
What?
Oh my god!
It's like he's a...
That's okay, don't worry.
I'm worrying.
He's jumping, he's like, fucking where is he going?
Oh my god, it's because he does Hadookin!
Yeah, he has one of those two.
I think for your your head buts you just have to wait a bit in between them so like you can get your hand players.
Okay.
Oh no, oh no.
The problem with that is you use all your cage.
I might have messed up there.
I got a little too excited.
You still have your supers.
So if he gets on you again, you can try and do a super.
Oh my god, he's not letting me do anything.
Guys, I want to go back to iron.
Oh, you want to rem...
Okay.
You can farm me.
You can farm me, I guess.
I didn't grab him.
But he grabs me?
Wait!
Wait, I don't have...
for for his grab you have to do like the regular grab oh the regular where you're great what is the regular grab guys it's L2 it's L2 he does he's giving me the throw loot okay but what if I throw you back oh he won't let me throw him back that's fine nice that's it that's it I have a Oh no,
he doesn't need a coach.
Oh no, that was a little.
I was trying to myself too.
Now I know why I turned it off.
Now I know why I turned off the controls.
I don't know.
i thought i thought you would stop fighting me it's okay as long as as the other new players don't learn ryu and the other guy can i know there's an aki and a jury wait do they counter me aki has a fireball but the thing is if you learn butt slam you can also get over the fireball with butt slam so you could try doing that like because you just need one of them to go over right okay we got this we start off with the butt slab they won't know oh he left he did not want to fight me
also you can steer the butt slam to go like left and right how do you see oh do you like these hold left or right to make it go closer or farther what like you do the input for it yeah it's kind of confusing like right after you do the input you hold left or right oh it was with the with the jump no like so like you do like you do the bus time normally and then right when you're going up in the air you hold the direction what what
all right that's that's for day two maybe that's a bit too hard yeah just try and get the bus out first oh my gosh i peaked in my first game i don't think i can hit that that doha and it again well get that marissa back
i get it spamming
please honda work with me honda please sometimes you're pressing the punch too early now you just gotta make sure you're pressing it like pretty much at the same time can i have a charge when i'm in the mid-air like does that where does it have to be like when i land it no you can charge in mid-air so like right after you start charging yeah wait that Oh,
okay.
Never mind.
That doesn't change anything.
What?
It's close though.
You're definitely getting the charge.
I mean, I think it's just an input after you're missing.
Oh my god, please.
Please, Aunda, work with me.
We gotta work together.
I think you have to wait like a little longer than you are.
Aunda, please.
And then that one you're pressing the punch.
I'll be early.
Okay.
Oh, Honda, please!
We have three days!
Oh my god.
One is enough, I guess.
Yeah, you can get one, that's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we'll do that.
One is enough.
One is enough for day one.
Okay.
Why does no one want to fight me?
I got rejected five times.
Yeah, try and put it on three to five when it lets you pull up the menu again.
Let's see.
Oh, three to five.
Wait, so who are the other characters that I'm playing against?
Oh, this guy.
Yeah, this character and Aria.
at least okay hello kevin oh my god i got a social security number it might as well all right watch this oh um almost almost it almost worked what she blocks that okay i gotta make sure i don't i don't accidentally
Hello.
Oh god, she knows.
She knows that.
I'm not a natural.
That's right.
I didn't mean to do that, but that's right.
That's looking right.
Oh no.
What?
Yay!
Because I killed her.
If they're really low on life, you can just do it.
Because they can't do it back.
That's fine.
Hello.
Oh shit, not hello.
Oh no.
Yeah, I grabbed you back, girl.
That's right.
My loyal fans.
I hope they found this.
That's what he means in the inside.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Oh, hello?
Hello?
Oh!
Yo,
please, leave me alone.
Haha!
Oh, shit.
That's right.
Goodbye.
Oh wait, I should practice the OOPs.
Sorry, I was just messing with him.
That's okay.
I forgot.
I have to practice again.
I think you know the matchup.
You just gotta learn the other two, bro.
Okay.
I will get this to work in game.
Oh, wait!
Wait, that's three!
And stop getting it!
Okay, five is the limit.
That was good though.
I did it.
That's more than one.
Look at that.
Three?
Three.
All right.
Okay.
Three.
Oh my god, please.
Please, Honda.
We were doing working so well.
We're in sync.
Please.
No.
You know what?
I'm going to raise, I'm going to lower the bar even more.
That'll be fine, right?
Two is a bit scary, but you could try it.
Yeah, yeah, like it'll be scary for them too.
You know?
That is true.
Like, it'll be scary for them.
If I, if they have bad, I have fiber, so it'd be less scary.
There's no way the other team has fiber.
Yeah, probably not.
Yeah, yeah.
So my input should go first.
That's how it works, right?
Not really, but if you think it does, then maybe...
Oh, yeah, because it's...
In fighting games, it's like the shittier internet wins, right?
Yeah, or at least it's like balanced.
Like they kind of...
It's just the total connection, basically, because you're connecting to each other, not a server.
Wait, then how does lag switching work?
Um, like it makes it laggy for both sides, basically.
Yeah, but how come the person who lag switches wins?
It's because, like, if you actually have a lag switch, you do it, like, during another person's combo.
Oh, that's so smart.
And how does, like, theoretically, someone get a lag switch?
Yeah, I don't know about that.
Really great.
That's a joke, Capcom.
Capcom, that's a joke.
That's a joke.
I would never.
That's a good question, Lil.
Yeah, this is a good question.
Like, I was one...
It's a joke.
Oh, my God.
It's him.
It's Big Slop.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
I learned another move.
Okay, but that's it.
That's it.
Oh, he's trying to throw me again.
Nice.
bro get out of here go just wake up
oh my god yeah i think if you have your like just keep your charge and try and head but when he jumps he's trying to time it i'm fighting back bro guys i'm trying i swear to god i'm trying to fight back
that's right it's mine oh my god he's too far what what did he do to me what did he do to me oh i'm not letting you farm me you're farming me enough can sometimes do like the not easy headbutt version because that one i think doesn't go as far as the other one wait not easy headbutt like the the one where you like press forward in the button instead of like the special one oh i swear to god oh no it's the hog okay he's someone else okay it doesn't give you the same person twice in a row
Oh my god, he's just like me.
Do I get my first cast?
That's fucking right.
Oh no.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
That's fucking right.
Oh my god, we both fucked up.
But he has better anti-air.
Oh no.
like he knows combos or something.
Yeah, I mean, he's on modern too, so he's just doing the auto combos.
What the?
Oh, what?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Get out of here!
My turn!
Oh my god, never mind, it's not my turn.
Oh, I timed it right.
What the fuck?
I can't please.
Oh my god, please.
His antires are pretty good because he's on Modern 2.
That's okay.
You're not firing me out of there.
It's okay.
None of them are learning Ken, right?
As long as they don't know.
They don't know I can't deal with Ken.
There's one other player, but I don't know who he's playing it.
Alright, that's fine.
As long as he's not playing Ken, we're okay.
i'm worried okay it's okay guys i can learn against all my other matchups
wait so what do i do against ken if they find out i can't deal with ken um you can try so try doing like your jump but like try hitting your button um like in the air yeah and try to try to make it hit them okay the the heavy it's the circle circle oh so So you wanted to hit them and then you do your auto heavy.
Ah, oh, auto heavy.
That or like you go into the combo after either one works.
Oh, like that.
Oh, I see.
So that way, if you jump over a fireball, you get like a big, oopsie big combo.
Two, we're both here.
Oh my God, we're both here to suffer.
yeah oh she's bronze yeah this should be free then unless unless he's smurfing oh wait she blocked i think she's you're not new yeah oh yeah i can't believe it there's no way there's no way she's fucking with me she's actually with me there's no way There's no way!
There's no way she's frowned!
I refuse to believe this.
She's playing the slowest fucking Kami game of my life.
That's it!
That's right!
Oh, I didn't know that toy at all.
What did I do?
I mean, it doesn't do anything bad.
It didn't hit you for a while.
Why am I?
I hate you.
I hate you, Kami.
That's a key.
Right!
That's fucking right!
Oh my god, she counters.
What?
Oh my god, she's lag switching.
Chose the wrong person to lag switch.
I don't know how to...
I hate her.
She's making me block.
Hmm.
oh i'm on the right side whoops yeah you thought you were the one with all the life i was looking at my green meter and i was like how did i lose my green meter she blocks too much about i'll do one more
yeah i think if you would just wait a bit more then you'll you'll do a lot better oh thank god she left
Yeah, because a lot of people are jumping, so if you just wait and then you have your charge to anti-hear them.
Okay.
Um, yeah.
Oh, Jerry, that's my matchup.
Yeah.
He's a dealer hot.
Good name.
Oh, freaking freak.
Get out of here.
Freak!
There is no way.
I'm putting you some fucking prodigies right now.
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, and you jump over that?
There is no way.
Get out of my lobby.
Okay.
I like that.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Yeah, you could have died back on that one.
That took you right.
Get out of here!
Oh, never mind.
I guess I'll get out of here.
Oh.
Oh my god, she's making me laugh.
What is wrong with you?
Get out!
Okay.
There we go.
I don't like it.
I can play so slow.
Why am I...
She's just getting lucky.
Where the fuck am I?
Okay.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, it's over.
It was a good try.
Yeah, it was definitely a good try.
You almost came back.
Alright.
Oh, I wanted to do my butt slam, but she was first.
Oh.
nice oh yeah she called that one out oh no okay
oh unlucky come on oh shit how did she know I wanted to spam it
yeah there you can just kind of wait and if she does a DI you do super back and then you try and wait for your drive get to come back oh you're super i think r3 or l3 i forget this one all right oh that's my r3
oh that's bad yeah so here you just wait and do your super like she does something weird goodbye i just gotta charge oh get out of here
it's all about keeping your charge for headbutt.
Nice.
That's looking right.
Get out of here!
Oh.
Oh, she fucking...
She's using her brain.
I don't like that.
No.
What the fuck?
Get out.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, no.
yeah you still have your super nice get out oh no i don't have anything yeah when you don't have anything you have to try and jump the okay
i'm adapting though i'm figuring it out yeah i think like the supers have been really good now and the headbutt timing is a lot better now too okay i just need to figure this out And then I'd be unstoppable.
Who's her?
That's my.
I don't know if she... Yeah, I don't think she was out when you played Sage Emslam last time.
Oh, okay.
Wait, is she... Is anyone playing her?
Is it any of my matchups?
I don't think so.
That's fucking... Oh, never mind.
That... Oh...
That's fucking right.
That's right.
that's oh shit never mind it's okay and when they're burned out you can spam drive impact because they don't have it to do it back
haha oh shit yeah but she gets it back when you stun her on the wall like that but when you get the stun you can do a full combo so you do your heavy auto combo oh I see yeah that's right jump again but like I need you to get closer What the fuck?
What the fuck?
Yeah, the fan bouncing on you.
What the fuck am I looking at?
Oh, I fucked up.
It's okay.
Oh.
Wait, how do I dodge?
I just, I felt I couldn't jump that.
Yeah, you can't jump it.
When the bounce is on you, you just have to block.
It's crazy.
There you go.
Nice.
That's right.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Okay.
She's scared.
Yeah.
She saw me do the neutral and she got scared.
Yeah, I think that's what happened.
Yeah.
I think it's actually steaming Wait a minute.
I think online mode is off.
yeah wait was there servant maintenance where's the internet yeah steam maintenance every tuesday i think oh my god it's tuesday they'll come back soon though oh no i didn't even realize trying to do the butt slams oh yeah that's true that's true then someone will tell you when it's back yeah chat tell me when it's his back guys Okay.
The moment I learn my fifth move, I'll be unstoppable.
Okay, I gotta be on this side though.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, please.
I lost my groove.
please you can press down a lot earlier than you're pressing it through the second one yeah but also you you might be holding up so i can't really tell
oh wait wait i got it i got it okay but it didn't hit but i got it yeah so that's where the steering comes in you gotta you gotta make sure it hits i thought i got it
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please, Honda.
Work with me.
Honda, please.
Honda.
We can do this, Honda.
We just got hit two in a row.
There we go.
Now maybe three in a row.
Oh my god, maybe four.
Okay, no, that's too much.
That's asking too much.
No, that was good though.
There you go.
Yeah, there's still a big gap between when you're like, um, inputting it and when you hold down though.
So if you can make that a bit smaller then you can get it to come out faster for the, like second one.
Oh my god.
These guys gotta shorten the gap.
No!
I was in the groove!
Yeah, you had it.
Oh my god.
Oh, Steam is back.
Nice.
Oh, that's a fast mage.
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah, I was like, I've never seen it go that fast before.
Why do I go back online?
Uh, go...
Um...
Yeah, you can do it here.
Wait, what?
Do you guys lie?
It's still a town.
Who was it?
Who's the one guy?
That's crazy.
Oh, my God.
Who are you?
Sir, I wish you were back.
Oh, wait, we're back.
Okay, no, never mind.
He is telling the truth.
You're fine.
I was going to ban you, but you're okay now.
No one.
One guy is me.
I was already at it.
You know what?
I'm feeling a little dangerous.
Oh, that's not what I want to do.
Oh.
Alright.
You don't need to hit triangle.
Oh.
It worked though.
It was giving me my groove.
It does work.
I was vibing with the triangle.
Oh no.
What kind of freak is playing JV in this ELO?
Oh, yo, he's a smurf.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
Oh, no.
Stop.
That's sucking right, old man.
That's sucking right.
I got fiber.
that's looking right okay get out of here
all right i'm gonna try this oh he knows oh shit he oh shit oh my god he was fucking with me bro you just gotta get close that one you're just blocking him he was fucking with me that's so fucked up Hold on, when you get it here, you win.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
He knows.
Oh, no.
My dog is not happy, too.
Oh, my God.
You freak.
That's right.
My dog's cheering me on!
That's right!
I broke your win streak!
Fuck you!
And I leave!
Yeah, you're really mad now.
No!
That's right, I win with the power of my dog.
Hmm.
That's fucking right.
No win streak for you.
Alright.
One day I'll be able to use this move.
Wait, I figured this out.
I mean, I feel like you've got it.
I got it in theory.
Only in theory.
Oh my god, the famine.
Yeah, they can't do that to Honda.
Oh, wait, that's a nice costume.
That second right.
oh my gosh she grabbed me what do i do i grab her back that's right i up my charge and i worked out
that's right the two moves i just need to know yeah you don't need very much yeah also when you have like a big life lead you can all just like send back a lot more you don't have to go in too much oh come on you know you want to jump come on come on
girl oh oh
shit oh shit okay that's not good that's right
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Yeah, you can wait for your drivers to come back.
Oh.
There you go.
Yay, that's a real silver player.
Let's go.
Oh, he left?
i win i win the mental game see when i fight real silver players i have a chance they're all smurfed yeah yeah everyone i lose to are smurfing that's how it goes no that makes sense yeah yeah like why would a new player know how to block that doesn't make sense also i don't think i explained supers but uh if you hold a direction it gives you a different super so if you hold so like if you press super with like nothing it gives you like your level one but if you hold down it gives you level three what control is that like down and then i think r3 oh okay okay i got it that makes sense oh that's right oh sorry that's right that's right
okay yeah i mean i feel like you're getting the hang of it yeah event wait okay i could test this out because she's not that good Oh shit, never mind!
If all else fails!
Oh shit.
She grabbed me.
Oh whoa.
What are you doing here?
Alright, okay.
Well, I mean that works too.
Oh wait, I'm on the other side.
Come
on!
Hello?
Oh no.
Eventually one of the torpedo will hit.
Yeah, one of them.
They're too easy.
I got a new challenge.
Alright, one day I will use this.
all right if i do it enough it will hit my head i'll realize how what's how to do it yeah i think you're just not charging long enough because like if you see the numbers on the left it says like you're holding down for like a certain amount of time it has to be at least 50 i think oh okay oh
50.
god that feels so long
like the first one you have to wait a long time but the other ones because you can charge while you're in the air like oh okay but those ones where you just get the heavy punch you're pressing the heavy too early yeah you see how it says they're pressing the punch like before the up yeah
get in here oh no never mind please leave
It's big slop!
Okay, thank god.
It's not big slop.
You don't like that guy?
No, fuck that guy.
Go back to his real Elo.
That's goddamn right.
Get out of here!
That's for blocking.
That's right.
We ain't blocking here.
Oh, wait, fuck, okay.
Maybe a little block wouldn't hurt.
Yeah, there's a way.
Yeah.
Oh shit, sorry.
Oh no, oh no.
Yeah!
Got it back first.
All right, maybe.
Yeah!
Oh shit, what's the point if he can block that?
He's adapting.
Am I fighting game?
Oh, God.
Yeah, that's what you get.
Get out of here.
That's right.
I got my level three now.
He doesn't die, does he?
No, not yet.
But you can try to do a butt slam.
Close it out.
Alright.
mid-feet i mean you got it oh i still win goodbye i don't want to fight kens right
it's okay we don't need to learn kens guys no one plays kens oh zero bar okay let's see how this goes he and i are both desperate oh my god if he shows up yeah this is not looking good um um this ain't looking so good this maybe accepting zero bar was not the play all right kiki hey
we both are suffering today unless i need you be on this side because i can only fight on this side That's right.
Oh, I thought he got that.
Oh my god, what is he doing to me?
It's okay, doesn't matter.
Zero bar advantage.
All right.
Ow!
All they do is just block it!
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
He doesn't like it.
No!
Please!
I'm trying to... No!
You're going to distract him.
He knows!
Oh no.
Oh my no!
No!
Can't get another noise complain.
That's fucking right.
I didn't even realize I don't block down.
Get out of here.
Oh, no.
That's right.
I did.
I have the advantage.
Yeah, you're climbing.
Goodbye, Kiki, because I need to feed my dog.
Give me a sec.
All right.
Oh, no!
The guy left.
Oh, he also left.
Yeah.
Wait, so like, how do I use this efficiently?
Because I used it twice, but both times the guy blocked me.
Even if it gets blocked you can keep doing it kind of.
Oh, okay.
This is my rank up.
Please ma'am Please I have a tournament you don't
That's fucking right throw it out of oh wait never mind
Get out of here ma'am Oh, I That's right.
Oh shit
She jumps?
That's okay.
Do I get mine first?
Yay!
Get out of here!
That's right.
You wish you were built like this.
Hmm.
Oh, what the heck?
I don't know what I did.
That looked cool.
That's funky right.
Oh, I thought I got that off.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
It's not actually that much damage.
That's good.
Oh.
No.
Okay, you have three bars and she has zero.
Okay.
Gotta be able to get that.
Get it off.
like right now yeah I think it's okay to do that like even when you don't get the GI yeah just stick around sometimes throw it randomly
oh that's not cool
that's right oh that's not good oh no oh no
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here!
Okay Renko?
Yay!
Level two!
Goodbye.
I farmed you enough.
Yippee!
Okay.
I still need to figure this jumping thing out.
Or is this guy?
Oh shit, he's also gonna rank up.
He thinks I'm a splurf.
Little does he know?
I just know.
Oh, fuck.
Little do I know.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is he doing to me?
Who broke your win streak?
Jesus Christ.
Um.
i don't feel so good that's okay still how is he so much fasting he's actually built different
um uh you can try you can try doing your jump in more than me oh what oh oh shit okay okay i live
that's accurate oh he jumped who would have thought bro he knows my range you freak
oh my god whoever broke your win streak like
oh almost um that's okay it's her first time yeah playing this guy yeah
I don't know if I won't play against him again.
I...
Oh, I'm gonna make him.
He's gonna see me think.
Oh, oh, and he gave...
I won.
Yeah, you did win.
He wasn't patient enough.
I would have rematched him if he waited.
Hello.
Yama?
Round one.
Oh shit.
That's messed up.
What the fuck?
Oh, she's on Modern.
Yay.
Okay, maybe I should...
Oh.
Oh, what the fuck happened to me?
That's okay.
We both...
Okay, never mind.
It's not okay anymore.
anymore.
That's not okay.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Oh, she won't let me do that charge.
What's wrong with you?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
That's okay.
The brain is so big
it's so much bigger than mine oh my god and you jump get out of here
oh my god is anyone playing cami uh i don't think so at least not the two that i know about that's all i need to know not like
one one point I will be able to use this oh jury yeah that is good practice all right jury let's do this give me that rank up please oh my gosh she knows my
Oh my god.
There you go.
That might be bad.
Oh that is very bad.
I'll give her a hug though.
You don't need to do your EX headbut like when they're waking up.
basically the same as your regular headbutt then it's only when the something gets blocked you can do it oh do i not use it for match like mixup though no because it's like it it's just basically a punishable version of your regular headbutt i see yeah for mixup you do that yeah the command grab let's get out of here that's a congruent Give me my ring cup.
Yay!
Wait.
That's right.
I need to farm you.
I have a tournament.
Oh my god, maybe she'll find me.
It's like she adapted to my playstyle.
I don't think so.
Ha ha ha.
My coach said, you don't know what you're doing.
Oh, wait, I messed that up.
You can do your own combo, so.
When they're like wall spotted like that after the DI, you can still do your combo.
I'm doing like, oh, the O combo?
Yeah, the O combo.
wait do i like perfectly counter him or no no no an error who's error oh hers that's why hers that's yeah it is that's right you coward you look at coward that's it again oh okay that's right I made someone play okay eventually this will work hey coward can't even deal with my spam all right I know I'll heal it okay never mind she goes first apparently
Jesus oh my god what oh my god in this classic that's okay that's okay that's okay
that's right
get out of here I don't even know how I did that Oh shit!
Oh no.
You think I don't know how to break that?
That's right, my turn!
Oh wait, maybe it is.
Get out!
How do I...
How do I do that grab again?
I do that by mashing.
This is down and special.
Yeah, that one.
Sometimes, like, it works because I just...
Yeah.
It's like my SOS.
Oh.
It's okay.
I know all about you, Kami.
All you do is jump.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm downloaded.
I'm in her head!
And now I'll leave, because now she'll hate me forever.
Yeah, that's smart.
She'll wish, she'll always try to queue up trying to find me.
Oh shit!
The match of the century.
This is the first beef I've seen.
Oh no.
oh nice that's right i know your moves i was you oh shit never mind he hallowed me just like old times oh no i used to do that all the time too
oh my god bro he's spitting yeah just try and jump when he gets close Okay.
Oh my god, I used to do that all the time too.
Oh, not the Siberian bear hug!
Oh no!
I think he...
That's fucking right, get out of here.
Oh my god.
What?!
No!
I don't know.
I'm thinking.
No, I have to learn.
You may have to do some butt slams.
Oh no.
Okay.
Please, sir, I'm trying to learn how to butt slam.
oh my god i think he knows i'm trying to learn there you go
oh no
oh my god he's so much better why could i do that and keep
when you get closer i think you're gonna just do your auto um circle combo hit oh oh he just grabs me yeah when things don't work out he's gonna grab so you gotta jump oh this gif actually knows combos oh but yeah please that first oh i got hit no no perfect for
You're perfect now!
Oh, that's fine.
I won without...
I won... I won because he didn't get a perfect out of me.
Yeah, that is a win.
That's a win.
Mentally, that's a win for me.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Good practice.
Oh my god, she's so many points higher than me.
Are you trying to fuck with me?
Like, are you not dodging on purpose?
Like...
Oh shit.
Oh shit, give me a sec.
I'm not very good at platforming.
What is wrong with you?
Only I can spam moves.
Oh.
Get out!
Nice.
I had it with you.
Yeah, I wasn't dodging on purpose, guys.
Oh.
Oh no.
Get out.
That's right!
Oh shit.
What?
She can do that?
That's where I hit you at the other time.
She can...
Holy shit, what is she doing?
What?
Get out of here!
I think she's dead actually.
Oh, okay.
What the fuck?
How did I get the reset?
Yeah, he's got to mash harder.
Oh, nice.
Oh my god.
That's your clip of the day.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Okay.
Oh, I wanted to do that.
I was trying to charge it up.
Oh.
I like that.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Wait, she's doing combos.
Don't wait.
How do I get out?
Yeah, she seems to know some combos.
Her is dead.
How did she do that?
That's right.
I got level three, girl.
Get out of here.
I don't need combos.
I have auto.
Yeah.
That was a good perfect.
I don't know how I did it.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
That was so fast!
Um...
There you go.
Oh no!
I'm in a bubble!
Okay.
I got you now!
Get out of here!
Yay!
I got a friend request too!
Okay, this is it.
This is good.
I still don't know how to do this, but this is good.
I don't know how to put that in in rank.
Yeah, if you're just holding down and back, like you're charging both butt slam and headbutt too.
So if you see them jump at you, you can just I could do both buttons?
Yeah.
Okay, that didn't work out so well for me, though.
Oh my god, this guy...
Oh my god.
Wait.
Please.
Get up.
Oh my god, he knows how to jump.
Oh no.
Oh my god, I'm trying to grab.
Nice try.
Okay.
Oh shit!
Use the wrong button there.
Oh my god he keeps jumping like a freak!
Get out!
I like that.
Okay.
But I'm doing it.
My turn.
Oh.
Okay, maybe your turn.
Okay, yeah, it is your turn.
It is your turn, I guess.
No, that's fine.
That's okay.
Yeah.
Oh,
shit.
One.
Oh, no, not again!
It's okay.
Okay, we know the matchup now, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
I fought so many Kens.
It should be five.
Yeah, but then he's gonna be like, oh no, one bar Honda.
He's also scared.
Yeah.
What comes here?
Yeah, see?
Oh, no, one bar Honda.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, this is actually one bar Honda.
What is this?
I do not feel so good.
Yeah, 300 ping is crazy.
We're both suffering.
We suffered.
We know what we were getting into.
We killed Annie.
That's fucking right.
Let's drive impact there.
Oh my god, wait, he has the right idea.
How do I dodge her?
Oh my god.
There we go.
We did it.
We got close enough.
He's doing a lot of EXTPs.
You got Blackbeard.
I'm feeling like he's in the moon right now.
Oh my god!
It's okay.
Bro, he's molded by this ping.
I feel like he knows.
This is not his first rodeo.
This is probably why he practices it.
Yeah, this is not his first rodeo on this godforsaken ping.
That's fine.
We're out of here.
The guy with zero ping was easier than the guy with one ping.
Yeah.
No, he felt like it felt like he knew what he was doing in 300 ping.
I don't know how I feel about that.
Yeah, I think he has a strategy for that.
He's molded by it.
It was literally his only option.
Hello.
Hello, Ray.
What?
Oh, thank you.
That's right.
You're too close!
That's right!
Let's get out!
Get out of here!
Oh.
Oh, he anti-enemy.
He's messed up.
That's right.
I'll grab you back too.
Nice!
And then my combo.
One button.
Yay!
I didn't need to.
It's about the message.
Mm-hmm.
Yay!
It's easy.
Hey, it's not cool.
Oh my god, this is actually not cool Wait, wait a minute I don't like this She adapted, but I have it Um SOS
Okay JK Okay No SOS
Oh, what the fuck Yay
Okay.
Oh my god, that's hard too?
What is wrong with you?
Oh my gosh, I'm in the fire.
I'm scared.
Wait, I'm scared actually.
Wait a minute.
She's not stopping.
Oh wait.
That's okay.
Um.
Yeah, I think you just have to hold your charge more.
Huh?
Um, she's not easy anymore.
Alright.
That's not fair!
Oh no, that is actually not fair.
Oh, she's getting- No!
I don't understand.
Yeah, that movie just had to block the whole thing.
You had to block it?
You might have to do a bit of blocking.
There we go.
I like that.
Oh my gosh, she's so fast.
It's fucking red.
Oh, shit.
Now she waits for me.
Oh.
what oh my god how is she doing all that yeah yeah it beats your di so you got you got to do do drive reversal or super if you're gonna wake up with something
what um sos sos
Okay.
SOS.
I don't think I killed her.
No, she's not dead.
Yeah.
You could try and DI her into like order, but she might super.
Yay!
Shit.
Okay.
i don't i she is scary
there you go that's where you that combo again i got you don't wait oh not that though
nice oh my god i wasn't yet stop okay Oh, I didn't charge it.
I hate this move so much.
That's fucking right!
Oh my god, I'm sorry.
Tapped it!
Yay!
Yeah, that was a good learning how to deal with that triple kick move.
Yeah, yeah, I saw her jump and I was like, that's it.
That's my one opportunity.
I still don't know how to do this, though.
That's okay.
Tomorrow you got it for sure.
Yeah.
Tomorrow.
Tomorrow I'll be slamming that out everywhere.
Oh, yay!
My matchup!
Hello, Mr. My Fluffinkins.
If you're a dragon, can you please throw?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't know I was.
Hey!
Oh my god, she...
It's a stream sniper!
Oh.
Here we go.
That's right.
I don't care if you're my fan.
I'm gonna kill you.
Yeah, you can't care about that.
Yeah, that's right.
Wait, actually, stand still!
Stand there!
I need to practice my move.
you stand there oh okay it's not oh wait give me a sec i'm gonna learn this move give me a sec
okay okay okay okay there you go just stand there you're in my practice
i'll make it work oh my god please
This is good.
You're doing real match practice.
Stop!
Here you go.
There you go.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
oh wait no no wait get out of here i win
all right wait i'm making work wait wait wait wait wait wait wait it's working oh okay all right now we fight for real fight me for real i did it Oh That's right.
We fighting for real now Oh my and I'm holding I'm holding this thing and then so I could do it.
Oh never mind Oh never mind Here you
Oh my god, wait stop wait she's she also is fighting for real.
Wait, no, no That's okay Oh my god.
I don't think I live this.
Yeah, I don't think so, but...
You got one bar and she's got zero, so you should win this.
That's true, that's true.
That's true.
That's right, super hit.
Oh, every time.
Oh my god, and then she knows I'm going to grab.
It's like she's been watching me this entire fight.
Yeah, that's weird.
Yeah, how does she know my every strat?
That's right.
Huh?
Don't worry, I'll block this eventually.
I'll give you a hug first.
That's right!
What move would I do next?
Try the platforming?
Yay!
Okay.
We did it!
Wait, what are you gonna say?
That was a good platforming.
Yay!
I did the platforming.
Oh.
She slid below me.
Ha ha ha ha!
Oh.
You can just do that?
But...
Oh, oh nice Yay Billy Pat
Get out of here
Not cool Oh shit Oh Oh my god, no, stranger Oh, wait, what would happen to my HP?
I was full Yeah yeah she's definitely hit you a few times oh my god i thought i had full hp
good get over here get over here oh get over here oh if she does that again you can try and grab it i can grab that oh do it again do it what come on do it again oh Get over here!
What?
Almost, almost.
Get over!
Oh!
Yay!
All right, keep doing that.
Keep doing that.
She's going to do that too.
She doesn't have it anymore.
Oh, okay.
Because she's burned out.
Oh, my God.
She's playing with me.
I don't like it.
That's right.
Oh.
My platform.
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna do something oh never mind i'll just i'll just do that again oh
god please don't shoot me i don't understand how can she move like that he's just playing with me like she's smurfing something yeah I think this guy actually is smurfing it's like he knows how to play the game
so not used to the range being so so dope
good night
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Where are all these combos?
I've never seen before.
What?
How do I even...
How do I even get out of that?
Alright.
I'll take that.
Oh my god, please don't play with me.
Please, sir.
Oh no, that's not why I went.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Okay.
All right, I'm locking it all.
I don't think I'm locking in.
I didn't.
My.
Oh my god, please.
Nice.
Like, like she just jumps away from me.
Yeah.
Whoa!
I am tired!
Unintentionally.
No, that was nice.
so all right slam dunk oh my god i thought i'm that
more oh oh oh no no no that is yeah get out yeah i did it yeah i think might be like but i did it yeah that was that was a legit win i think yeah
is maybe like meta i feel like everyone's playing her or she just yeah a little bit no she came out a while ago i think a lot of people just play her because she's she's just a great character oh wait what is the what's the best character currently um a lot of people say either like her or Bison or JP you love you.
It's not like super clear because like all the characters are pretty close.
What makes what makes JP so so good?
It's because like he just like deletes your drive gauge.
It's like what she's doing to me.
Yeah.
Please don't.
That's my- oh shit!
That's not right.
That's not okay.
Oh, we both got the same idea.
Oh.
That's my turn.
Holy shit, she does so much damage though.
Yeah, she does do a lot of damage.
Oh!
Oh my god, this is why you're on a two-win streak.
Oh my god, this is why.
We've got three-win streak now.
Oh no!
First, she baited me.
Alright, I'll fight you again.
I'll let you have a four-win streak.
I'm less!
Oh.
I feel like she downloaded me.
I don't know how.
I don't think so.
What?
Oh, I don't know, that's bad.
Oh.
She knows.
She knows I'm fucked up right now.
Oh, oranges.
No!
Oh, she does so much.
That's right, I'm dodging that.
Okay.
I don't know right here.
What?
I think she's downloading me.
Unless...
What would I do now?
Surely not this move?
Oh.
Nice.
You'll never know what comes next.
What would I do next?
Surely.
Oh, that's right.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit.
I guess not.
That's okay.
I did a mix-up.
Oh, no.
But what would I do after that, though?
Oh.
Oh, no, never mind.
Um...
Okay.
Oh, no.
No!
Oh, no, she got her full win streak.
No, not the full win streak.
You got some butt slams there, though.
I'm figuring it out.
I got the butt slam!
the bus slam hit yeah they did hit oh oh i guess the guy left where i could go up all right god please please uninstall because he plays ken yeah
uninstall now no one likes you because you're on ken Oh,
what?
Excuse me.
What the fuck?
God, you're such a loser.
That's fucking right.
Fuck that up.
You're such a loser.
God.
Oh, whoops.
What?
It's like a threat.
Why not?
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Oh my god he punishes me.
It's a little too early.
Yeah.
Oh.
I hate you.
Bro.
What's up with all you guys with your goddamn win streaks?
No!
Oh, hey, good buddy.
That's right.
That's right!
Pow!
Get out of here!
What would I do next?
Who?
Oh, that.
Never mind.
That's actually fine.
Because you should win this round and then they won't have the bar anymore.
Theoretically, I should.
Yeah.
There's actually no way you lose this.
No, don't say that.
Um, no, no.
Not the jinx.
No.
Oh, no.
Um.
Yay.
Oh.
What would I do next?
I wonder.
Oh, oh, he knew what I was gonna do next.
He didn't have to wonder.
Yeah!
Do that one more time.
Wait, I got new cheese!
I win!
Yeah, they just...
if they're just stuck blocking you just wait i can just do that i'm not fighting him again i can wait why didn't you tell me sooner yeah if they press a button like that one isn't actually good but like on knockdown or if they're just blocking a lot oh my god i did i got my fifth move that's my fifth move i don't need this i i don't need this anymore
all right all right next game's my lg next game my lg yeah it's not good yeah yeah yeah i feel like you learned a lot already yeah yeah yeah i got the fiber engine in the brain too yeah all right cammy
this one's my lg oh wait hello she's european
oh you thought that that's gonna stop me oh my god maybe it will that's right oh no no she she did stop me oh just for a second though
oh no She stopped me!
Oh.
That's fine.
I have this.
Oh.
That's right.
Get out!
My lobby!
Haha!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, she's doing mix-ups.
Yeah, kind of.
Doing baby mix-ups, but it works.
Oh, no.
No!
Yay!
1HB!
What would I do?
I wonder.
That's right, she didn't know I was going to do that.
Is she?
Oh.
what was that I want to keep my three mm-hmm oh no oh
my god wait wait a minute wait chill chill chill I shouldn't have kept my three oh no I messed up
Okay, that's it.
This is the LG.
Yeah, I think you should have spent it.
Oh.
Oh no, I didn't charge it.
She knows.
She knows I haven't, I'm not charging it.
She's so smart.
Haha, now I'm in the groove.
Oh.
It's not cool.
Oh, she jumps so much.
I don't like it.
Yeah, you'd have to wait for that in headbutt.
I'm tired of it.
I'm tired of your jumping.
Get out of my lobby.
Can't jump forever.
That's right.
Round two.
I saw that
That's right I knew you want to block I'm thinking right You want block again?
That's right Oh shit Okay I'm sorry I'm sorry man But am I?
Not actually that's sorry Oh no I'm
sorry Oh Yay
that's okay i won yay yeah if you if you wanted to do the level three you just had to do it like raw like without the combo wait how do you do it raw like just down in um l3 l3 oh okay down l3 okay i got it oh yeah oh that's recording oh yeah um press press start here like it'll it'll work yeah press um or actually wait is it r3 press r3 okay I'm not sure.
I need to get rid of matchmaking.
Get out of here.
Okay.
Oh.
Hello.
Hello, sir.
Okay, never mind.
You go.
Press press press press start.
What start?
It's not that one.
Yeah, that one.
Yeah.
Go in shortcut settings.
Okay.
i've never been on this area turn all yeah turn um the recording ones off yeah those ones um yeah turn those off i think you press uh let me look you press x to turn it off or triangle look you press triangle okay okay that should work now oh okay now i know now i know to use this yay okay now i know how to do it raw oh i can you write that down i might not i might not know i might i might forget
yeah i'll send you some notes after yeah okay thank you nephew for coaching i think i learned a lot yeah i think so you're getting coached by a big bird tomorrow right Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Big Brits coming in tomorrow for additional coaching.
Yeah, he should teach you some good stuff.
Whoa!
He might teach me a seventh move.
No, a sixth move.
But that might be a bit too much.
I don't know, actually.
He could just help you perfect the ones you know.
Yeah, yeah, he'll perfect my five moves.
I got the combo.
If they start blocking, I do this.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
They're never expected.
Yeah, I don't think so.
guys and then I can do this too but thank you nephew for the coaching do you have letters coach coaching after this or uh I think the last one for it today but I coached you on the before GG's thank you again I'll try my best I'll try and win one game at the tournament that's my goal I mean I think it can be all of them really yeah I think so how much you want to bet
I don't think that's a good bet if you're in control of that.
I'll do my best.
I'll do my Gigi's though.
Gigi's.
Thank you again.
They're going to say thank you to Nephew for coaching, guys.
Thank you, Nephew.
I'll practice more tonight.
All right.
Yeah, let me know if you need any more help or have any questions or anything.
Bye-bye.
each thank you again to nephew for coaching guys i think i learned a lot i actually did i actually did i learned a lot today um but um yeah at first i didn't know any moves now i know this move now yeah yeah i started going crazy i adapted guys i told you i can death and then tomorrow big bird will perfect these moves i don't know how i don't know guys honestly i hate to break it to you guys but i don't think we're doing this move wait unless wait unless oh my god wait wait a minute wait wait no nephew are you watching
wait wait anyway that was a great coaching session i man why does it work unless he he's not here it's not fair why he can't even witness this i'm so sad i finally i did it and my coach wasn't here to see it but thank you again everyone for supporting today's coaching session i think you know i think we did pretty well the moment he leaves But,
um, Mr. Opokens, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you, me, Smurf, I would never.
But I'll try and practice more tonight.
Um, I am, I am very nervous.
I am very nervous about, uh, on Friday, like I said, uh, it is like, you know, a lot to learn.
But like, the thing is, they can adapt to me in time, I feel like.
if i if you know if i do get all of it the thing okay also three of the people two of the people um two of the people that's on my bracket they also have to do say jam slam as well so uh they they also have to do say jam slam so like we don't have to worry about that like okay we do have to worry but they have to have two two different games you know two different games uh to to practice for so we got that in our pocket i only have one game right now yeah i only have one game to practice for um yeah no no it's different inputs guys it's different inputs they'll have twice as much they gotta split their headspace you know i just need one drive they need two uh n7 they give a super chat thank you thank you thanks for the stream don't you think Thank you everyone for the support.
Guys, thank you all for watching.
I really appreciate it.
I hope you guys have fun time hanging out with me.
I'm going to try and practice more tonight.
And yeah, it's going to be a really packed schedule this week, like I said.
But it's been fun.
It's been so fun so far.
But I always thank you guys so much for the support.
It feels like I think we might tournament i don't know actually i don't know i felt like this move in particular uh might be it i don't know i mean we're doing so well with this move in general i don't know i feel like i don't know if i can lock in on gif in time in terms of like how i'm feeling about honda like after i figured out,
like, some of the move?
I lost to a Gif.
No, I lost to a Gif.
She was just better.
Like, yeah.
The thing is, I don't know.
It's the thing about Zang Gif is I have to play so slow.
I feel like.
I feel like I have to play really slow.
Which play style is more comfortable?
I just feel like I have to play more, like, slower than usual.
That's why I don't, I'm worried.
yeah he feels a lot slower while when i was on honda i literally i just fucking headbutt my way forward yeah that's the only thing i'm really um worried about now because like pre-nerf i didn't have to play that slow anymore um like not not anymore but i feel like pre-nerf his play style was not as slow as it was for honda um Um,
so, um, I feel like I have to be much more calculative when I do my grapple and my jumps.
You never use his nerf moves.
That's the thing.
I don't know moves you use gets nerfed.
But, like, if he feels a lot slower.
Or maybe my head is way too fast for Gif.
Yeah.
Maybe tomorrow we'll try Zane Gif and then I'll be like, I learned harder today.
Anyway, can I try Zangiv from BigBree?
Like...
Giv is just low in general.
The thing is, the thing I do...
They do like about Giv is the fact that I miss this jump grapple.
You know?
I can punish people so easily if they jump around me.
Because this one...
This one.
That's what I miss.
I missed that and then obviously like he has very He has good grappler Yeah the jump grab Yeah I don't know I do miss Zangief though To my for my loyal fans I do miss it I will admit This is fun
This is fun This is fun This is fun I will admit.
But I was enjoying Honda a lot.
My loyal dragoons.
Yeah, the supers, yeah.
My raw supers, yeah.
That's what I was known for.
I say...
De-Honda.
That's true.
My De-Honda's.
I did, but I did do a lot of, I did lab a lot for De-Honda though.
God, I'm so conflicted, guys.
I'm so conflicted, chat.
I don't know.
Give it a day?
I'll give it a day.
I'll I'll ask Big Bird if he can coach me on Gif a little bit?
Oh.
I don't know.
I'm still so conflicted.
I felt like I was learning so much on Honda, too.
Yeah.
I was learning so much.
I'm so conflicted, Chad.
I don't know.
I'm so conflicted.
Gif fallback?
Do I do a Gif fallback?
Okay, but I could do it.
Wait.
Wait, what was the move that I was like?
Oh, my.
Oh, yeah, this.
This move is cool.
I want to do that in a match, though.
That's what I want to do.
That's true.
They are expecting Zengi.
How about tomorrow?
I'll do a little bit of coaching.
little bit coaching with Big Bird, with Zangief.
I'll do split coaching with Honda and Zangief.
And then on day two, I'll figure it out.
I'll figure it out.
Which won't be my main.
Because like I said, I know everyone knows me for my Zangief too.
Everyone knows me for my Zangief.
So like I said, it's just... It's so difficult!
It's so difficult!
Oh, no.
I don't think Brawlpo want to coach the competition, guys.
I...
Guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but Brawl Pro is also in this tournament, and he is on the enemy team.
Yeah, the damage is lower.
That's the only...
That's another thing I don't like.
It is very low damage.
I will admit.
What is it?
It's like this, right?
Where's Iha?
Iha.
How do I do the green thing?
Yeah, I saw that.
Oh, it's this.
I was like, how do you do the green thing again?
What?
How did I do that?
How did I do that again?
What the fuck?
Wait, don't press tap forward twice.
What?
Oh, okay.
I remember I used to abuse that a lot too.
And then I did this to fuck with people.
I remember I would do that.
And then I'd be like, boom.
And I don't remember how to grab that.
And then I'd be like, I do this.
Yeah, it's so good.
It's such a good bit.
And then I'd be like, whoa.
And then I'd be like, yeehaw.
But that was old dokey.
geef all right tomorrow tomorrow we'll talk with big bird and then um have him coach me a little bit of geef and um and i'll see how the vibe feels uh yeah i have to i have to think a lot playing zane geef was such a mind game i felt like as d honda as d honda it was literally like head butt I don't even know what it was.
I don't know what it was.
And so I thought I was just like, headbutt.
And then like, I'm like, oh, you're blocking.
Grab.
Yeah.
Yeah, all right.
All right.
I'm going to call you guys.
Always everybody.
Say hi, Jaden.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
An immune cell from me.
Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.